you know airs interesting thing one of
the financial principles that I found in
working with people that build wealth is
you become who you hang around with yeah
that's a financial principle you become
who you hang around with you know I was
in New York City the other day and did
you know all those people speak with an
accent you become who you hang around
with and you know I know some people
they're Yankees that came down here to
the south and visited and they said they
said we had an accent I don't know what
made him think that
but in that funny you become who you
hang around you know if you know you
don't let your kid run around with
juvenile delinquents because you know
your kid will be a juvenile delinquent
if little Johnny down the streets of
we'd head you know if your kid hangs out
with him your kids going to be a weed
head
we know that did you know that your
income will be within 10 to 15 percent
of the average of your ten closest
friends income some of your going I need
some new friends now I'm not talking
about in a given month but over a period
of time your speech patterns your
character your alcohol consumption the
books you read how much television you
watch your level of education is
dramatically affected by the people you
run around with you have a tendency to
approximate the people you run around
with think about the last few books you
read or did you hear about them the
people you run around with my wife has
got some friends that are watching some
of these TV shows and she's driving me
bananas to watch some of these TV shows
why cuz of who she runs around with the
crown and what is it the I don't know
just couple these shows about Queen
Victoria bouncing around I think there's
two different ones right now I haven't
seen them yet they're probably pretty
good but I'm not making a judgment the
point is is that you become a you hang
around with if you value education it's
probably because you've hung around with
people even including your family the
value education
it's a financial principle because all
these things affect your income all
these things affect you know if you hang
around with a bunch of people that spin
spin spin spin spin spin guess what
you're going to do you're going to spin
spin spin spin spin spin if you hang
around too much people that save save
save save save save you're a tightwad
but yeah I mean it interesting the power
even when we're adults I'm an old guy I
mean I'm 56 years old and the power of
peer pressure is real it's real and a
positive and in a negative way the Bible
says do not be deceived
bad company ruins good morals and so
part of your financial plan is is if you
run around a bunch of people to borrow
money on the credit cards all the time
you're going to have credit card debt
you're going around with a whole bunch
of people to tell you all the time all
you can't be a student without a student
loan and guess what you're going to have
student loan debt that's how it works we
have this unbelievable powerful
gravitational pull as humans to conform
to our environment so the only thing you
got to do is you have to choose your
environment a little more carefully and
you can choose you don't have to be mean
or nasty and I'm not saying be a snob
and look down on people I'm not saying
that at all but I've noticed when I quit
running around with people that had a
trash mouth that my trash mouth went
away that was a couple of decades back
but you know neighborhood I grew up in
men women we said stuff you're not
supposed to say you know a different era
and a different time and it's called
white trash is what it's called but
anyway I'll help you with that but not
saying my neighborhood was white trash
but I was how I talked it was awful and
you don't want to talk that way you're
not going to succeed that way people
don't respect people to think like that
and talk like that and so I had to
change hello you can change you can
choose choice powerful thing joining us
more powerful than your tendency to
confirm to inform so be careful because
you're going to conform be careful
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]